Judy you've worked with Ken is it so
many times it's not worth going into 30
years including when I asked her about
being in this she was the first person I
asked to be on the train and she very
kindly said yes before I'd finished the
sentence and it was that was very
thrilling because it made a big
difference to everybody else but I used
to go and talk to her about it in our
dressing room at the Garrick Theatre
where we were doing Shakespeare's play
at the Winter's Tale and going into
Judy's dressing room was always like
going into the bookies because she's
there I'm studying Shakespeare like a
wild thing she's bent over the sporting
life I'm going there one night having a
chance it's a very exciting may have
Johnny Johnny Depp maybe in a show and
Michelle Pfeiffer is like Josh catch
each other that's thrilling she was
sitting there with a dressing-gown oh we
get our call over the town Oh mr. Branum
is dense you're you're pure on so she
gets up we continue talking great so
we're gonna build a train and it's all
gonna be fantastic we get into the wings
ready to go on there's 30 seconds to go
she throws off her dressing gown and
there's nothing on from below the waist
I can confirm like the song there is
nothing like a day but we then that's
every day so Judy says dress have to run
all the way back to the dressing room
come back on with it with her skirt and
then she walked on like that and then
all the things she used to do like that
she couldn't do doing the rest of the
see when somebody acting in semaphore
you notice it's quite surprised
[Music]